The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.
Remember that our program is mostly funded
by members who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom,
you'll get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show, as well as The Daily
Bonus Show.
The bonus show is an extra show every day
just for our members.
It's a beautiful thing.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
For me, popularity contests are not a good
way to measure the worth of anything.
I think we need to think more deeply, more
critically, to find out whether something
is good or bad, a valuable or worthless worth
doing or not worth doing.
But there's a big contingent that supports
Donald Trump, as well as to Donald Trump personally,
to whom everything is popularity, its approval
rating.
It's the size of Trump's crowd.
It's that type of thing.
And along these lines is a very triggering
poll for Donald Trump, which has already been
released.
And it shows that Joe Biden is already weeks
before taking office more popular than Donald
Trump has ever been during his entire presidency.
The numbers are really stunning.
Gallup has been tracking presidential approval
for decades, both during transition periods
and presidencies.
And Joe Biden's approval has risen to 55 percent
already.
And this is a number that Trump has never
reached during his entire presidency.
Trump never got to 50 percent and has currently
dipped down to 42 percent approval, while
Joe Biden has jumped to 55 percent.
And something very interesting are the sort
of internals of these numbers, how they're
made up in terms of party, where we see that
over the month, from mid-October to mid-November,
Biden's approval among Republicans doubled.
The numbers are still low, but it doubled
from six to 12.
Biden's approval among independents is up
seven points, forty eight to fifty five.
And it's basically unchanged changed among
Democrats because it was already at 95 percent.
It went to ninety six.
Now, Donald Trump's approval also hasn't changed.
Among Democrats, it's at three percent.
It was at three percent before and it's at
three percent now.
Independent approval of Trump is almost unchanged,
down two points.
But Trump among Republicans has lost six points
of approval.
So there's a few important aspects to the
story.
No.
One, Trump has been and remains a historically
unpopular president.
Trump is the outlier here.
Typically, the president elect gets a bump
when they're awaiting inauguration.
Trump never got that back in November of twenty
sixteen, December of twenty sixteen and the
first part of January 2016.
And in the end, that's not really surprising
because in 2016, remember that Donald Trump
won electorally with the biggest popular vote
loss of anything we've seen for a winning
president.
But there is actually more to this.
The reason I care about this is not just Trump
will be triggered, OK?
What we have right now is a situation where
we will be changing federal leadership in
the middle of the absolute worst moment in
the United States of a global hundred year
pandemic.
The importance of Joe Biden building goodwill
with as many people in the United States as
possible can't possibly be overstated.
And if Biden's approval has already jumped
to 55 percent, presumably at least some of
it because Joe Biden formed a coronavirus
task force, has actually provided some parallel
leadership to Trump when it comes to the virus,
has announced he'll be bringing on Anthony
Fauci as chief medical adviser.
Hopefully, people are seeing the approach
of Biden and are reacting to it with good
will because on day one, Joe Biden is going
to have to spring into action.
Now, of course, on Biden will be inaugurated
January 20th.
You know, and I know that on January 21st,
January twenty third, maybe at the latest,
Republicans will start blaming Biden for coronavirus
deaths, even though, of course, all of this
has to do with the federal failure to start
testing and deal with this seriously at the
beginning, cases and deaths reflect activity
weeks and months prior.
OK, we already know that.
But on day one, Joe Biden is going to come
in and he's going to say, let's listen to
the science and medical community.
And if we see Joe Biden spike to maybe 60
percent approval or 60 to hopefully he will
get as much of the country as possible on
board with working together to deal with the
virus.
That's the top priority right now.
Presidents come and go tracking approval rating
is not very important in the abstract, but
right now we've had as many as two hundred
and thirty thousand coronavirus cases in a
day.
We're starting to see days with 3000 deaths.
We are starting to see vaccines hopefully
rolling out this month.
Presidential approval actually right now connects
with saving lives in that it will signal buy
in with.
What incoming President Joe Biden will likely
be asking people to do, including wearing
masks when he's sworn in and yes.
The optics of highly triggered rebel popularity
obsessed Trump already being outdone by Joe
Biden's approval before Biden is even president,
I do admit that it's funny in a sense, but
it also is very important